messieurs madame la rapporteur nous
poursuivons les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition de
Monsieur Philippe truelle président
directeur général et Olivier Truel
administrateur des laboratoires CDM
Lavoisier que je remercie de cette
mobilisée pour cette audition nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui messieurs afin de
recueillir le point de vue des PME de
santé et sous-traitants pharmaceutiques
souvent désignée par leur acronyme
anglo-saxon CDMO
bien que moi connu du grand public que
les Big Pharma il joue un rôle
déterminant dans le tissu industriel
français et l'approvisionnement de notre
pays en médicament essentiels je note
ainsi que les PME de santé représentent
34,4% soit plus d'un tiers des ventes
totales de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeurs les fameux MTM
consommés en France
j'ajoute que Monsieur Philippe Truel et
membre du comité exécutif de pôle Pharma
que nous avions sollicité par ailleurs
vous pourrez donc nous faire partager
l'analyse et les propositions de cette
organisme qui structure la filière
biopharmaceutique française et dont les
membres sont aussi divers pour ne citer
que quelques exemples que l'université
de Tours
que nous avons d'ailleurs auditionné
également où le LEM
proximité indépendance et sécurité
sanitaire maillage du territoire ces
mots sont omniprésents dans le débat
public mais peine à trouver dans notre
pays une traduction du point de vue des
politiques publiques or ils sont le
socle commun d'éléments naturels des
entreprises comme la vôtre naturellement
positionné sur le fabriqué en France
bien avant que ce sujet ne soit sur
toutes les lèvres vous êtes donc
particulièrement bien placé pour faire
entendre la voix spécifique des moyens
laboratoires entre guillemets et
indiquer un chemin peut-être en matière
de lutte contre les pénuries de produits
de santé et singulièrement dans cette
commission de médicaments cette voie
singulière dont vous déplorez
régulièrement au gré de vos
interventions publiques qu'elle soit mal
reconnues par les autorités vous l'avez
porté notamment Monsieur Philippe
truelle dans le cadre de l'âme lisse
association des moyens laboratoires et
industries de santé
vous avez présidé cette association et
vous en êtes aujourd'hui le
vice-président après avoir été le chef
de fil des PME au sein du LEM de 2015 à
vous exploitez une trentaine d'AMM dont
les trois quarts sont des médicaments
d'intérêt majeurs le chlorure de sodium
le fameux NaCl le potassium ou la
morphine sous forme sous forme
injectable il s'agit en majorité de
médicaments du quotidien ou commodité
dont le prix moyen est bas mais qu'il
soit indispensable dans l'arsenal bien
qu'il soit indispensable dans
l'arsenalthérapeutique de nos médecins
le chlorure de sodium en l'occurrence
est une réalité votre témoignage est
d'autant plus essentiel que les formes
injectables sont plus particulièrement
sujettes aux pénurie par comparaison
avec les autres formes galéniques elle
représente 10% des médicaments consommés
mais selon le LaM plus de 50% des
ruptures d'approvisionnement vous nous
direz si ces chiffres sont toujours
valables surtout 8% de votre activité
seulement se fait à l'export et 92% à
destination des services des soins de
soins français il nous importe à cet
égard de comprendre ce qui fait la
viabilité de votre modèle économique
l'absence d'attractivité du marché
français concernant au moins les
produits d'immaddi mature qui est
souvent pointu du doigt je ne citerai
que les propos du directeur général d'un
grand laboratoire français Pierre Fabre
le nommer quant à médicament est exporcé
exporté à moins de 50 % il est en risque
ce qui sauve les produits ce sont les
exportations
paradoxe absolu or je l'ai dit vous
exportez très marginalement quant à
votre activité de sous-traitance elle se
fait auprès d'acteur aussi variés que le
LFB coloplace à nos filles pasteur ou
l'AP-HP
dans quelle mesure les médicaments
consommés en France doivent-ils et
peuvent-ils être produits en France
jusqu'au l'exigence de souveraineté
industrielle peut-elle remonter sa chez
centre de bien très particulier dont le
prix est administré et dont la chaîne de
production est parfois très complexe et
composée de nombreuses étapes de la
chimi fine notamment depuis les matières
premières qui servent à constituer les
principes actifs et les exceptions à la
distribution en passant la distribution
qui va jusque dans l'officine dans les
territoires en passant par la
fabrication du produit fini et le
conditionnement
tels sont quelques-unes des questions
que nous échanges permettent doivent
permettre d'éclairer avant d'aller plus
loin je vais vous céder et je vais vous
céder la parole pour un bref propos
introductif j'insiste sur le Bref madame
Laurence Cohen rapporter heureux de
notre commission d'enquête vous poserez
une première série de questions comme
vous l'aurez compris notre commission
d'enquête entend obtenir des réponses
étayées à des questions précises
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles à son grand-4-13 424-14 et
434-15 du code pénal je vous invite à
prêter sermon de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure Monsieur
Philippe Truel
je jure vous avez la parole
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur
madame la sénatrice messieurs les
sénateurs
tout d'abord je souhaiterais commencer
mes propos en vous remerciant d'avoir
souhaité nous auditionner en effet vous
l'avez rappelé comme d'autres PME
indépendantes françaises nous
représentons une frange de cette
industrie qui est silencieuse et peu
visible
à la fois de nos concitoyens mais aussi
bien souvent des pouvoirs publics
les laboratoires CDM Lavoisier sont une
entreprise industrielle constituée de
135 femmes et hommes fondés en 1888
et dans laquelle j'ai l'honneur de
travailler depuis maintenant 23 ans en
tant que représentant d'une quatrième
génération de dirigeants familiaux vous
avez noté lors de votre arrivée le lien
de parenté qui nous liait puisque
Olivier et mon frère et mon deuxième
frère Jean-Marie est aussi actionnaire
de l'entreprise
vous l'avez aussi rappelé la raison
d'être d'une entreprise comme la nôtre
c'est depuis l'origine de mettre au
point de fabriquer et de distribuer des
médicaments essentiels puisque la
majorité d'entre eux on a parlé
plusieurs fois de liste de MTM de Miss
de médicaments critiques mais ces
médicaments depuis très longtemps sont
classés comme essentiel par l'OMS et il
n'y a pas de débat sur le sujet
ce sont uniquement des formes
injectables donc des situations
d'emplois particulières dans des
domaines comme l'anesthésie rénimation
la prise en charge de la douleur
cela demande évidemment à savoir faire
de pointes et le respect d'exigence
réglementaire très strict et qui n'ont
cessé c'est un facteur sur lequel on se
permettra de revenir dans quelques
instants
donc au quotidien nous fabriquons une
commercialisons cette trentaine d'AMM
qui se décline en 150 présentations
différentes puisque au sein d'une même
am vous avez cité le plan de sodium on
va retrouver des poches des flacons des
ampoules qui vont du 2 ml jusqu'au litre
pour répondre à l'édifié aux différents
cas d'emploi des professionnels de santé
qui prennent en charge nos concitoyens
leurs usages évidemment et bien établi
depuis de nombreuses années aussi bien à
l'hôpital qu'en ville puisque la France
a énormément développé du temps des
plans Kouchner l'hospitalisation à
domicile et je pense au bénéfice de
notre système de soins
ce sont donc plus de 30 millions de
doses de médicaments qui sortent chaque
année de notre usine de production
située en région en Loir-et-Cher
nous travaillons majoritairement avec
des fournisseurs locaux des partenaires
puisque pour la plupart ce sont des
entreprises avec qui nous travaillons
depuis des dizaines d'années
88% de nos principes actifs proviennent
d'Europe dont un tiers de France
et 68% de nos composants de production
de France et 100% d'Europe
donc effectivement c'est un élément pour
nous de stabilité et de sécurité en
termes d'approvisionnement néanmoins ça
ne fait pas tout et on pourra rentrer
dans un certain nombre d'exemples
notre savoir-faire aujourd'hui repose
essentiellement sur la compétence de nos
équipes et j'en profite pour leur rendre
hommage à travers ces quelques mots
parce que je dirais le développement la
présence de l'entreprise ça réactivité
dans un certain nombre de situations que
ce soit la canicule de 2003 qui est la
première crise sanitaire à laquelle nous
avons fait face où la crise de la covid
plus récemment à résider uniquement dans
les femmes et les hommes qui la
constitue
ce savoir-faire vous l'avez aussi
rappelé nous le mobilisons régulièrement
pour fabriquer d'autres produits de
santé et d'autres médicaments
d'entreprises ou d'entités tiers dont
des établissements publics ce sont des
solvants pour vaccins ce sont des
solvants pour reconstituer le médicament
en poudre des préparations hospitalières
en partenariat avec l'établissement de
production de la PHP ou des matières
premières à usage pharmaceutique
vous l'avez aussi rappelé nous
appartenons à plusieurs collectifs au
sein de notre de notre secteur lamnis
bien sûr que vous avez aussi auditionné
au travers de sa présidente madame Pinon
qui représente aujourd'hui une
soixantaine de TPE et PME du secteur le
LEM l'organisation professionnelle des
entreprises du médicament et enfin Paul
Farma qui fédère la filière industrielle
pharmaceutique et biopharmaceutique en
France
et notamment je pense dans certaines
réponses aux questions que vous nous
poserez je reprendrai vraisemblablement
à mon compte un certain nombre des
propositions qu'ils ont faites puisque
aussi bien le LEM que Paul Pharma au
travers du xis ou d'autres dispositifs
ont déjà depuis plusieurs années fait
des propositions d'action
comme la plupart des entreprises
jusqu'à il y a une dizaine d'années
nous n'avions pas à faire face à ces
situations de rupture de stock à
l'exception de la situation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure de canicule de
2003 mais qui était évidemment une
situation très particulière et en partie
imprévisible et depuis et c'est sûrement
un exemple je pense à déployer il y a eu
un travail en commun fait entre les
industriels
le secteur de santé l'ANSM pour
anticiper chaque année ces situations et
s'assurer de la constitution de stocks
suffisant et détecter le plus en amont
possible la moindre variation de
consommation
les différents représentants que vous
avez auditionné ont déjà largement
illustré les causes des tensions
d'approvisionnement voire de pénurie de
médicaments ça a été dit et je
le partage c'est évidemment
multifactoriel très complexe et souvent
mal compris
par des personnes qui ne sont pas
directement dans le secteur les causes
elles sont de deux ordres principaux
structurels et conjoncturels la hausse
de la demande ça a été dit qui a été
plus vite plus rapidement que la hausse
des capacités de production des
approvisionnements en matière première
et composants qui sont devenus de plus
en plus compliqués notamment à l'issue
de la crise de la crise covid avec une
concentration de l'offre et là aussi une
baisse parfois de capacité chez un
certain nombre de nos fournisseurs
la réduction de l'offre aussi sur le
marché on voit sur nos propres marchés
des médicaments ou il y a encore une
dizaine d'années il y avait quatre
acteurs et on est passé à trois acteurs
voir à deux acteurs et donc évidemment
ça devient plus compliqué de couvrir des
marchés très quantitatifs uniquement à
deux entreprises
les normes de qualité qui sont devenus
aussi de plus en plus complexes et qui a
minima rallonge les temps de cycle je
l'ai évoqué lors de la conférence de
presse qui avait été réalisé par le lait
mais il y a quelques jours sur le plan
d'action proposé par l'industrie il y a
une quinzaine d'années sur nos
médicaments qui sont des médicaments
injectables il y a un délin compressible
de sept jours entre le moment on
commence après produire le médicament et
le moment où on pourrait le
commercialiser dans le cas idéal
à l'époque on tenait une moyenne de 22
jours versus les 16 jours théoriques
aujourd'hui on est rendu à 45 jours
et ce long glissement est lié justement
à cette
multiplication d'étapes supplémentaires
de normes pour citer quelques exemples
la sérialisation est une petite étape
supplémentaire qui s'ajoute à la toute
fin du conditionnement du produit et qui
nécessite des vérifications
supplémentaires c'est du temps
basiquement du temps
et dans certains cas on réduit aussi
dans des petites proportions les
capacités de production puisque qui dit
une étape supplémentaire génère aussi un
petit pourcentage de défauts
supplémentaires
et aussi à notre sens peut entraver dans
certaines situations des mesures
d'atténuation rapide
les causes conjoncturelles la principale
et qui a déjà été évoqué aussi
longuement c'est évidemment le phénomène
d'inflation qui pour nous a commencé dès
l'été 2021 et qui s'est amplifié depuis
maintenant un an et demi en particulier
avec les phénomènes géopolitiques que
tout le monde connaît
nous considérons aujourd'hui que le
système actuel de financement du
médicament en tout cas pour les
médicaments qui ne concernent ne
fonctionnent plus et nous sommes je
dirais dans une forte attente de voir
quelles seront les conclusions de la
mission qui a été mise en place par la
première ministre sur le sujet
le budget global du médicament ne permet
plus de faire le en même temps de mettre
à disposition les médicaments matures du
quotidien essentiel de nos concitoyens
et les innovations de rupture qui sont
le plus en plus nombreuses et qui
apportent de réelles chances face à des
pathologies qui n'étaient pas prises en
compte avant
il faut donc donner à la HS et au CEPS
des outils pour évaluer
vraisemblablement type différemment
cette typologie de médicaments qui sont
devenus aujourd'hui très éloignés même
s'il ne faut pas nier que dans certaines
situations on a besoin des deux pour un
traitement anticancéreux très innovant
on a besoin de médicaments de prise en
charge de la douleur on a besoin de
solidité de perfusion
dans l'objectif national de
relocalisation qui a été aussi largement
déployés ces derniers mois il nous
semblait essentiel de protéger le tissu
industriel existant c'est évidemment
très important et très utile de pouvoir
installer de nouvelles usines mais
permettre aussi à celles qui sont en
place de continuer à se développer et
apporter de plus en plus de capacités de
production locale c'est pour moi un
enjeu
dans les actions qui nous semblent
essentielles et je terminerai mon propos
il faut vraiment
avoir des actions rapides sur
repenser ce système de financement
travailler aussi à mieux orienter la
commande publique
valoriser notre filière parce qu'on voit
qu'on rencontre des difficultés de plus
en plus prégnantes sur le recrutement de
nouvelles ressources s'engager dans une
démarche de d'optimisation réglementaire
revaloriser les prix des MITM ou
médicament essentiels produits
localement et enfin revoir et ce n'est
pas la moindre des actions le pilotage
de notre secteur on constate aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop d'actions disparates en
silo
et qui nuisent terriblement à
l'amélioration de la situation
merci beaucoup pour déjà cette
présentation déjà très complète
je vais donc tout de suite passer la
parole à Laurence Cohen rapporteur
merci Monsieur Truel pour votre
présentation effectivement qui qui pose
les problématiques si vous le voulez
bien je vais vous poser cette question
et je vais donc vous les poser en un
bloc donc voilà comme ça je pouvais les
noter pour pouvoir y répondre donc tout
va bien
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament à récemment révélé une
problématique de tension
d'approvisionnement sur le bicarbonate
de sodium Lavoisier
1,4 % que vous exploitez ce médicament
et notamment indiqué en cas d'acidité
élevé du sang est-ce que vous pouvez
m'apporter des précisions nous apporter
des précisions sur les causes des
tensions qui ont été observées
ma deuxième question c'est
ce qu'a dit le LEM notamment ce que
préconise le nem notamment lors d'une
conférence de presse c'est-à-dire de
mettre en place un observatoire ou un
haut commissaire plutôt aux médicaments
chargés de la lutte contre les pénuries
est-ce que vous partagez cette vision
des choses et comment vous envoyer le
pilotage nous avons
nous avons auditionné comme vous l'avez
souligné madame Karine Pinon qui est la
présidente de la MLI
et vous-même vous êtes le vice-président
donc elle a qualifié devant notre
commission d'enquête cette association
de petits frères du G5 santé dans quelle
mesure finalement les préoccupations que
vous avez souligné
diffère ou se rapproche de celle des
grands laboratoires et est-ce que vous
vous sentez finalement vraiment bien
représenté par les autorités de santé
est-ce qu'elles sont d'après vous
suffisamment sensibilisés aux
problématiques des PME
ma quatrième question c'est est-ce que
vous avez bénéficié des crédits de plan
relance et France 2030 et si oui est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner des exemples
précis des
aides dont vous avez bénéficié
ma cinquième question concerne votre
activité de façonnier sous-traitant
et qui se fait y compris pour le
bénéfice d'un certain nombre de
d'acteurs publics est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire dans quelle proportion et nous
avons notamment auditionné les
représentants de la geppes
vous connaissez bien la jette et ils ont
insisté sur la force du tissu des
sous-traitants en disant que ils étaient
capables de
fabriquer l'essentiel des formes qui
étaient nécessaires alors de votre point
de vue à vous est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que parmi les mesures que nous
pourrions prendre il ne faudrait pas
systématiser en fait les coopérations
sous pilotage publique sur le modèle qui
a été fait pendant la crise du covid
pour la production notamment du sisatra
curium entre santé publique France la
GEPS le passionné delfarme et les pays
de certains CHU
et si vous vous êtes de cet avis
finalement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire à quelles conditions on peut
réfléchir penser une telle organisation
et en même temps peut-être en soulignant
que vous-même si je ne me trompe pas
vous n'êtes pas chimiste donc est-ce que
ça ne pose pas des problèmes sur le fait
par exemple que vous ne puissiez pas
réaliser la fabrication de principes
actifs donc c'est une étape quand même
qui est essentielle et qui permet de
lutter contre les pénuries
mon avant-dernière question c'est vous
l'avez souligné et vous n'êtes pas les
seuls Vous demandez une augmentation du
prix des médicaments matures et un
moratoire sur les baisses de prix à
d'ores et déjà été décidé là encore nous
avons eu lors de nos auditions
des éléments qui sont contradictoires
c'est-à-dire qu'on a souligné par
exemple qu'un pays comme la Suisse qui a
des prix beaucoup plus élevé notamment
au niveau des antibiots des
antibiotiques mais pas que avec eux
absolument les mêmes les mêmes pénuries
voire des pénuries plus fortes que
celles de la France alors on est toutes
et tous ici bien d'accord pour dire que
de toute façon les causes des pénuries
des pénuries sont multifactorielles il y
a pas qu'un aspect des choses mais bien
souvent quand même lors de nos auditions
c'est le prix qui est mis en avant et ça
nous semble un peu un argument on va
dire facile enfin la dernière question
c'est sur les les recommandations
qui ont été qui ont été faites et qui
sont plutôt les les règles maintenant
qui qui sont mises à la votre
disposition puisque
vous avez
vous en fait non c'est pas est-ce que
vous avez c'est avez-vous sollicité
auprès du CEPS l'activation des articles
27 et 28 de l'accord-cadre qui permet
donc un laboratoire d'obtenir une
stabilité du prix faciale en
contrepartie d'investissements qui ont
été récemment réalisés ou à venir c'est
important cette question là parce que on
a eu le sentiment lors de nos auditions
qu'en fait c'est pas tellement
[Musique]
utiliser alors est-ce que vous êtes dans
le même sens est-ce que l'application de
l'article 65 de la LFSS pour 2022 qui
consacre la prise en compte du critère
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement du
marché français est-ce que là aussi
c'est parce que c'est un moment un
élément important dans la fixation du
prix est-ce que vous en êtes service à
vous semble une mesure importante
intéressante et de toute façon par
rapport aux questions que je vous pose
évidemment je vous demande si vous vous
pensez que ce sont des bons outils des
bons dispositifs mais si ça n'est pas le
cas évidemment donnez-nous vos arguments
pour montrer que ils sont insuffisants
ou ou inapproprié je vous remercie
vous avez la parole
merci Madame la rapporteur alors dans
l'ordre la première question concerne la
tension d'approvisionnement sur le
bicarbonate de sodium spécialité
fabriquée et exploitée par les
laboratoires depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années
aujourd'hui les tensions préexistent
principalement sur le marché de ville
parce que c'est à la fois un médicament
hospitalier et un médicament officinal
sur le marché hospitalier nous sommes
l'un des fournisseurs
avec une part de marché majoritaire mais
pas
pas total et nous sommes engagés dans
plusieurs appels d'offres publiques
auprès du ni achat auprès de la PHP et
nous délivrons les quantités attendues
sur ces marchés sur le marché officinal
depuis maintenant deux mois nous sommes
effectivement en difficulté sur un
marché que nous partageons il y a deux
acteurs qui fournissent ces spécialités
les laboratoires CDM Lavoisier et une
autre entreprise et les parts de marché
sont proches de l'équilibre c'est-à-dire
que l'autre acteur à 55% du marché et
nous en avons 45
depuis depuis le mois de février les
quantités que nous constatons qui sont
appelés par nos clients ont augmenté
d'une quinzaine de pour cent
. nous ne sommes pas en mesure de dire
si c'est une augmentation complète du
marché
ou si c'est je dirais une une moindre
livraison de l'autre acteur du marché
mais nous avons rendu ces informations
auprès de la NSM puisque nous avons
actuellement toutes les semaines des
points de suivi avec la NSM sur les
quantités que nous nous délivrons sur
les nouvelles fabrications qui sont
positionnées pour répondre à la demande
et aujourd'hui factuellement nous avons
livré sur un certain nombre de
références puisqu'il y a deux références
15% de plus que l'année dernière sur
cette même référence l'autre acteur est
français le tracteur est français
donc nous allons et nous avons une
réunion demain en fin d'air en fin
d'après-midi avec la NSM et les autres
les autres acteurs puisque vous le savez
il y a maintenant des dispositifs qui
sont en place où les acteurs rentrent
leur stocks et leurs prévisions de
production pour permettre à la NSM de
piloter puisque les données ne sont pas
partagées c'est la NSM qui à la
visibilité sur tous les stocks et les
capacités de production nous nous ne
savons pas ce que les autres acteurs
peuvent faire au fond et en fonction de
la réunion de demain elle nous donnera
éventuellement d'autres instructions
pour peut-être renforcer encore les
productions de nous mettrons à
disposition mais en l'état actuel des
choses nous considérons nous répondons
entre guillemets à notre responsabilité
sur le marché alors juste pour être sûr
d'avoir bien compris
d'après ce que j'ai compris vous
fournissez les mêmes quantités que que
voir un peu plus que donc et pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas en mesure de
savoir si c'est parce que il y a une
augmentation de la demande ou si c'est
parce que éventuellement l'autre
fournisseur je sais pas réduit ça
production je ne sais pas répondre non
mais c'était pour être sûr d'avoir bien
compris je vous remercie
sur le
sur le deuxième point
vous évoquez la
l'une des propositions qui a été faite
par le LEM de nomination d'un
haut-commissaire aux médicaments et en
particulier le rôle qu'il pourrait jouer
sur l'atténuation de ces situations
je l'ai évoqué un petit peu dans mon
propos liminaire on souffre depuis de
nombreuses années de ce fonctionnement
en silo qui génère même dans certaines
situations des injonctions
contradictoires où on va dire c'est très
important d'investir de relocaliser et
dans le même temps on va considérer
qu'on n'est pas toujours en mesure de
payer le prix d'une production française
et tant qu'on ne résoudra pas cette
équation en tant que toutes les parties
prenantes ne seront pas fédérées autour
de la table et d'un objectif commun on
aura toujours les mêmes difficultés donc
évidemment on soutient cette cette
proposition et cette
alors matérialité au commissaire ou
autre mais effectivement c'est sûrement
très important d'avoir une personne qui
est une fonction transministérielle et
qui puisse justement
agir et
coordonner les actions dans le bon sens
sur la question suivante
vous avez rappelé les propos de
Karine Pinon notre présidente
et notamment la proximité d'un certain
nombre de sujets partagés avec le sujet
[Musique]
ensuite vous avez rappelé
ce que vous avez peut-être
qualifié comme une contradiction
des entreprises du G5 qui a juste titre
un rappel qu'aujourd'hui lors de
développement et
leur marge se font majoritairement hors
du territoire national alors il y a
aussi des questions de proportion je
pense que pour la plupart d'entre elles
la majorité de leur chiffre d'affaires
est maintenant fait hors de France même
si l'empreinte industrielle reste très
forte en France et que c'est aussi un
bénéfice en termes de balance
commerciale
en ce qui nous concerne et c'est une
vraie question
le modèle je sais pas comment vous
l'avez qualifié modèle économique au
modèle d'entreprise qui a préexisté chez
nous jusqu'à maintenant et largement
déstabilisé par les dernières années que
nous avons rencontré puisque une
fabrication principalement française à
destination du marché français
aujourd'hui se heurte à un encabrement
sur des médicaments vous l'avez rappelé
avec un coup de un prix de vente compris
entre 1,20 et un euro 50 très fortement
à l'inflation des coûts les coûts de
l'énergie chez nous ont été multipliés
par quasiment trois en un an et demi
pour une usine c'est extrêmement
important
vous avez ensuite évoqué le plan France
relance 2030 alors nous nous sommes
inscrits dans l'itération précédente et
notamment l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêts capacités building qui était
dans le cadre de la crise covid-19 pour
lancer un investissement d'une nouvelle
ligne de production avec pour objectif
d'augmenter notre capacité de production
d'environ 15 millions d'unités de doses
de médicaments par an sur des petites
présentations en ampoule plastique ce
projet qui a duré deux ans qui a
mobilisé à peu près 10 millions d'euros
d'investissement
à bénéficier d'une aide qui n'est pas
complètement converti
à hauteur de 1,5 millions d'euros
si vous rapportez les ratios c'est un
très gros investissement pour une
entreprise comme la nôtre des millions
d'euros pour 15 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et donc un engagement
d'avenir et c'est vrai que dans la
période actuelle c'est un challenge
particulièrement élevé
dans la question suivante où vous avez
rappelé notre partenariat en tant que
façonnier avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs et notamment d'acteurs publics
j'ai cité vous avez cité tout à l'heure
la GEPS et qu'elle pourrait être
l'intérêt de ses collaborations
publiques privées
pour rappeler la jeunesse la jeunesse de
ce partenariat il y a déjà une vingtaine
d'années on fabriquait des médicaments
sous à mm pour la GEPS ça c'était le
début de notre relation et puis ces
médicaments sont tombés dans le domaine
concurrentiel donc la GEPS a cessé de
les exploiter et puis en 2007
lors de la décision de fermeture de
l'ufch de Libourne qui était un site de
production hébergé au sein d'un
établissement de santé la NSM a demandé
à lafs de reprendre
l'exploitation d'un certain nombre de
préparations hospitalières il y en avait
une quinzaine et c'est à ce moment là
que la s'est rapprochée de nous pour
qu'on puisse les industrialiser et
continuer à les produire en leur nom et
donc depuis on fabrique chaque année à
peu près 100 000 unités de ces
présentations hospitalières qui sont
vraiment des des médicaments de niche ou
qui dans certains cas servent comme
matière première pour des préparations
de poche de nutrition utiliser dans tous
les hôpitaux de France
donc je j'ai regardé évidemment avec
beaucoup d'intérêts l'audition de du
docteur Claude Bernard et de Renault
Catelan et je souscris je dirais
pleinement parce que je le vis de
l'Intérieur à ce qu'ils ont évoqué
aujourd'hui
le rêve d'un pôle public de production
qui aurait la capacité d'intervenir sur
des molécules et des présentations très
diverses c'est impossible c'est
impossible on voit bien déjà nous à
notre niveau qui ne sommes que dans
l'injectable et qui traitons déjà trois
formes différentes
tous les enjeux que ça représente et je
ne parle même pas des enjeux humains et
de savoir-faire quand on crée une
entreprise du départ recruté former les
gens acquérir le savoir-faire c'est
c'est extrêmement long par contre
effectivement ce savoir-faire que la GEF
a développé depuis des années à la fois
à travers un réseau de fournitures de
matières premières est-ce que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure est juste nous
n'avons pas la capacité de synthèse
chimique c'est hors de nos capacités
nous ne l'aurons jamais on a on a au
travers de nos activités développer des
partenariats avec un certain nombre de
fournisseurs qui pourraient le cas
échéant nous fournir d'autres molécules
que celles sur lesquelles on travaille
déjà mais la GEP c'est encore bien
au-delà de nous au travers de son
expertise et cette expertise elle se
déploie aussi au niveau du façonnage
puisqu'elle collabore avec de nombreuses
entreprises implantées sur le territoire
national qui ont des compétences en
forme chaise en forme injectable sous
tous types de de médicaments et donc
cette capacité elle existe elle est déjà
internationale et donc le pas d'après
c'est effectivement la mettre en
capacité de pouvoir se mobiliser pour
faire face à une certaine situation de
crise ce qui a été fait vous avez
rappelé sur le six attrackerium dans des
délais quand même assez assez
remarquables ou en anticipation de
situation à venir parce que on le sait
aussi et je pense que la NSM conduit
chaque année en observatoire des arrêts
de commercialisation
on pourrait je pense mieux anticiper
demain des tensions qui pourraient venir
sur certains médicaments du fait du
désengagement de certains acteurs ou de
l'augmentation de demande ou de
l'évolution de l'utilisation de certains
médicaments puisque là aussi les choses
évoluent ces dernières années ou des
nouvelles indications parfois sur des
médicaments bien établis apparaissent
vous avez ensuite évidemment c'est
c'est une question je pense qui est
surtout les lèvres de chacun d'entre
nous et évidemment de nos concitoyens le
prix des médicaments
je pense que c'est un sujet qui est
aussi divers et complexe que celui des
pénuries
et il se rejoignent au moins sur sur ce
critère
en ce qui nous concerne puisque je peux
pas parler de ce que je ne connais pas
mais sur nos médicaments qui sont des
médicaments essentiels techniques on
parle de médicaments injectables donc
ils mettent en oeuvre à chaque fois une
vingtaine de composants différents pour
arriver au produit final
quand on fait un ratio très rapide 30
millions de doses de médicaments 15
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
vous voyez un petit peu le prix moyen de
vente de ces médicaments sur le
territoire national aujourd'hui c'est
une réalité sur des prix qui pour la
plupart n'ont pas bougé depuis 15 ans
dans le meilleur des cas n'ont pas été
baissés puisque je le rappelle ça fait
aussi partie de je dirais du dispositif
de la convention avec le CPS et de la
corcade il peut y avoir des des baisses
de prix qui sont demandées aux
médicaments entre guillemets n'étant
plus ou brevet sachant que ces
médicaments n'ont jamais été sous
brevets ils sont issus de la pharmacopée
française on pourrait même dire que
c'est les premiers dégénérés sans en
avoir jamais le statut
aujourd'hui l'équation elle devient elle
devient extrêmement compliquée à la fois
remplir de plus en plus d'obligations et
de critères réglementaires et de qualité
on a rajouté la céréalisation sur un
certain nombre de ces médicaments on a
dû conduire des nouvelles études
vérifier l'absence de nitrosamines sur
des matières pourtant très bien connues
mais comme c'est un dispositif qui
s'applique à tout le monde
constituer des stocks de sécurité
supplémentaires c'est une mobilisation
de BFR évidemment
et voilà et tout ça c'est fait sans
financement à coup constant donc
forcément à un moment avec des
difficultés d'équation mathématiques que
vous comprenez bien
la dernière question vous avez évoqué
les deux articles qui ont été mis en
place récemment par le PLFSS dans
l'accord-cadre
sauf erreur de ma part l'article 65 ne
s'applique qu'au nouvelles inscriptions
et donc tous les médicaments en tout cas
exploité aujourd'hui par l'entreprise
sont des inscriptions anciennes donc ne
peuvent pas faire état de l'article 65
sur l'article 28 nous avions je l'avais
rappelé tout à l'heure
déjà commencé à subir le choc
d'inflation dès l'été 2021 donc dès le
mois d'octobre 2021 nous avons déposé un
dossier de demande de hausse de prix
auprès de chez EPS
après plusieurs mois nous avons reçu une
proposition
de hausse de 2 centimes sur le prix de
ce médicament qui était un euro 40
qui évidemment nous semblait
relativement éloigné de la réalité alors
les explications en étaient assez
simples c'est qu'à l'époque la doctrine
qui préexistait à l'application de cet
article
ne prenait en compte qu'un choc majeur
sur un des intrants donc il fallait
choisir un composant
qui aurait eu la plus la plus forte
exposition à l'inflation et on
appliquait uniquement
la quote-part de cette augmentation donc
évidemment c'était très limitatif et ça
s'appliquait souvent à la matière
première qui est sur certains de ces
médicaments est une part relativement
réduite du coup du coup global
aujourd'hui très objectivement c'est
quelques pourcents du coup là où les
coûts de production les coûts humains
les coûts supports sont devenus
préexistants
nous avons continué nous échanges y
compris avec un certain nombre de
direction ministérielles pour essayer de
faire valoir cette situation et
d'expliquer que
l'application stricte de cette doctrine
ne porterait pas de résultats suffisants
pour un certain nombre de situations
on a redéposé de nouvelles demandes il y
a quelques mois
à la fois sur ce produit et sur un autre
on a reçu une nouvelle proposition qui
est améliorée mais qui reste néanmoins
une très bonne bonne distance de la
réalité du coup de production de ce
produit puisque là aussi même si la
doctrine a évolué
le nombre d'éléments et de critères pris
en charge dans l'évaluation reste
limitatif par exemple les coûts humains
l'évolution des coûts humains n'est pas
considérée pour des coûts de production
français
je voudrais compléter de deux points
d'abord sur le sur le partenariat public
privé moi ça me semble un axe majeur
pour la souveraineté sanitaire française
je pense qu'on a en France des
structures comme la jette comme le
service de santé des armées comme le LFB
qui ont un savoir-faire vraiment unique
en Europe en tout cas et il faut il faut
vraiment renforcer ces structures et je
pense que ce renforcement passe par
l'extension de partenariat déjà existant
et de nouveaux partenariats avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques français
qui pourront porter des projets
peut-être plus ambitieux
aujourd'hui on travaille essentiellement
sur des médicaments de niche mais on
pourrait tout à fait imaginer que le
savoir-faire de ces structures soit mis
à contribution pour des projets sur des
nouvelles thérapies ou autre ensuite sur
le CEPS
c'est un exercice très compliqué pour le
CEPS aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont pris
entre les contraintes budgétaires qui
qui sont ce qu'elles sont vous les
connaissez mieux que nous puisque vous
votez chaque année le PLFSS
et puis de le côté les les associations
de patients qui attendent des nouveaux
traitements qui coûtent souvent très
cher à tort ou à raison c'est à chacun
se fera sa propre opinion
et nous dans notre position de petits
laboratoires qui produisons des
médicaments matures nous devons essayer
de continuer à survivre malgré les
baisses régulières de prix et la hausse
de coûts exponentielle en particulier
depuis trois ans
le CEPS a bien conscience de cette
situation malheureusement aujourd'hui il
n'a pas dans la doctrine la capacité de
l'adresser correctement
et il n'a pas visiblement reçu de
directives clair et net du gouvernement
pour aller au-delà de la doctrine à
l'instant je vous parle
et juste pour terminer la doctrine est
effectivement très importante et on sent
bien que c'est quelque chose qui les lie
et c'est normal mais il y a aussi une
question de financement et aujourd'hui
très clairement il n'y a pas de budget
mobilisé pour conduire nos doses de prix
donc une fois qu'on a dit cela
évidemment on va le déploiement de cet
article reste très limitatif et de toute
façon il s'autorégulent au travers de la
clause de sauvegarde donc ça veut dire
que quelque part chacun d'entre nous
quand je dis nous c'est les entreprises
du secteur
contribuera aux éventuelles hausse de
prix de son voisin ou à la ou à la
sienne
merci Pascal
la présidente monsieur moi j'aurais
voulu vous poser une question sur les
stocks
quel est votre politique en fait sur sur
les stocks que ce soit matière première
consommables préfinie ça fait partie des
sujets sur sur la pénurie qui devrait
porter le coût de ces de ces stocks
et est-ce que vous attendez quelque
chose de l'Union européenne parce que
moi je travaille plutôt sur ce sujet du
médicament avec ma collègue Laurence
haribet et d'ailleurs j'ai vu que vous
aviez mis mise en place d'un outil
électronique c'est une des
préconisations qu'on a faite dans un des
rapports que qu'on a fait et je voulais
je l'ai vu dans vos documents mais je ne
faisais pas entendu parler de la clause
de sauvegarde
merci
alors je vais peut-être revenir
directement sur la sur la clause de
sauvegarde je l'ai évoqué il y a
quelques instants puisque effectivement
c'est c'est aujourd'hui
pour moi
un système qui a été complètement dévoyé
de son objectif d'origine rappelons
l'objectif initial c'était pour assurer
à la solidarité nationale
l'intégrité du budget mis sur le
médicament et donc on considérait à
partir du moment où on avait voté un
budget qu'une partie du dépassement
devait être pris en charge par les
personnes à l'origine de ce dépassement
en l'occurrence les industriels
c'est un système qui a fonctionné qui a
préexisté dans depuis de nombreuses
années et qui a lentement glissé et
maintenant c'est dévoyé depuis on va
considérer quatre à cinq ans et on voit
que le phénomène est en train de de
dériver fortement je m'explique
aujourd'hui quand on a un système
régulatoire
qui dépasse quasiment 5 à 6% du budget
global parce que ce budget global n'est
pas complètement aligné avec les réels
besoins et les prévisibilité des besoins
ça ne peut plus fonctionner et quand en
plus au sein de ce système je dirais
c'est réparti entre l'ensemble des
acteurs
sachant qu'on intervient tous à des
niveaux différents avec des typologies
de médicaments différents c'est
particulièrement sensible pour vous
donner un exemple concret
cette clause de sauvegarde pour notre
entreprise qui réalise à peu près
la moitié de son chiffre d'affaires en
médicament remboursé
représentait il y a encore quatre ans
40000 euros de clause de sauvegarde donc
un montant relativement relativement
réduit mais avec un chiffre d'affaires
sur des médicaments très peu onéreux et
qui étaient stables c'est-à-dire le
chiffre d'affaires des médicaments
remboursés chez nous évoluent de 1,2%
donc nous contribue pas un dérapage de
des dépenses normalement
l'année dernière cette clause a été
multipliée par 4 alors même donc on est
passé à 160.000 euros alors même que le
chiffre d'affaires des médicaments
remboursés de l'entreprise c'était
réduit de 3%
. donc il y a plus aucune corrélation en
fait et pour une entreprise comme nous
c'est complètement imprévisible c'est
une taxe supplémentaire une taxe
sectorielle qu'on ne s'est pas prévoir
qui arrive quand elle arrive parce que
là aussi ces dernières années elle est
souvent arrivée avec grand décalage par
rapport aux échéances initiales plutôt
en fin d'année alors que normalement
elle doit être connue six mois après la
clôture de l'exercice et donc c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure dans le
dans les actions de
refonte du financement de notre système
de santé notamment des médicaments il
est essentiel de retravailler aussi sur
ce dispositif pour qu'il retrouve son
rôle initial et plus le rôle qu'on lui
fait jouer aujourd'hui
sur l'Union européenne sur l'Union
européenne
évidemment nous attendons énormément de
choses puisqu'aujourd'hui
l'Europe et le leader sur tous les
aspects de régulation de réglementation
et vous citiez c'est un bon exemple la
notice électronique et pour avoir vécu
de l'intérieur la crise sanitaire ou
dans certaines situations à la fois au
niveau européen mais dans les états les
autorités ont été capables de déployer
des mécanismes d'agilité réglementaire
pour justement faire face au mieux à la
situation je considère qu'on a
insuffisamment tiré tirer parti de ces
expériences pour être capable à la fois
de les redéployer dans d'autres
situations de crise mais aussi au
quotidien finalement si c'était possible
pourquoi dans certains cas ne les
limitée qu'à des situations de crise et
la notice électronique enfin c'est un
vieux sujet vous le connaissez sûrement
mieux que moi ça fait déjà plusieurs
années que ça a été mis sur la table
j'espère que je ne finirai pas ma
carrière avant de l'avoir vu mais c'est
essentiel c'est un mécanisme de
souplesse sa garantit d'avoir toujours
l'information à jour parce qu'une notice
papier elle périme à un moment
l'autorité introduit une nouvelle
information et c'est très difficile
d'être à jour à 100% alors qu'en
électronique vous avez la garantie
d'être à jour d'être disponible dans
toutes les langues et puis c'est
extrêmement écologique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on le sait sur un certain
nombre de noms médicaments où ce sont
des professionnels de santé qui
interviennent ils ne lisent pas la
notice il n'en ont pas besoin donc dans
notre cas il y a 80% des notices qui
sont qui sont détruites avant même
d'avoir été regardé
ensuite sur les aspects stocks et les
coûts
là aussi je dirais un petit peu comme
les prix les les stocks c'est
quelque chose qui est apparu être
l'alpha et l'oméga de la situation pour
beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs et notamment
d'acteurs extérieurs
c'est évidemment important d'avoir un
stock minimal d'ailleurs à l'issue de la
mission qui avait été lancé par
le Premier ministre il y a quelques
années la loi française a évolué et a
imposé des niveaux de stock
minimaux sur les MITM qui vont de 2 à 4
mois selon les typologies de médicaments
aujourd'hui de notre point de vue
comme d'autres choses si on a une
approche globale
et indifférencier on manquera dans bien
des cas l'objectif parce qu'il y a des
il y a des médicaments qui ont besoin
d'une approche particulière c'est
impossible d'avoir deux mois de stock
sur certains médicaments essentiels il y
a des médicaments radioactifs ils sont
fabriqués le matin pour être utilisés
l'après-midi donc vous aurez jamais de
moins de stock c'est impossible sur les
solutés de perfusion détenir deux mois
de stock en permanence c'est très
compliqué aussi parce que ça va
mobiliser des des fermes de stockage
néanmoins en période de canicule c'est
essentiel donc effectivement la moitié
de l'année c'est quelque chose qui est
entendu avec la NSM cette obligation
préexiste pour les différents fabricants
donc là aussi comme sur d'autres sujets
je pense qu'il faut vraiment se donner
les moyens collectivement d'aller
beaucoup plus finement et d'adapter nos
besoins à la réalité des produits à la
réalité des usages à la réalité des
territoires aussi peut-être que les
approches doivent être différentes entre
la métropole et les autres mères voilà
il y a vraiment cette nécessité d'aller
beaucoup plus dans le détail que de se
dire c'est de moi c'est 4 mois et on a
pu le voir enfin je vais reprendre je
suis désolé l'exemple initial de la
canicule mais même si à cette époque là
on avait eu 4 mois de vente de stock
standard on n'aurait pas pu faire face
parce que la vague a été tellement
importante en quelques semaines que ça
n'aurait rien changé en fait donc on
peut très bien se dire il faudrait 8 il
faudrait 10 mais à un moment quand on
est face à une crise majeure ça va bien
au-delà de de ça c'est des capacités de
réactivité de reproduction rapide plus
que d'avoir un stock énorme qui attend
le coût financier du stock
alors pour moi il doit être partagé il
doit être partagé à la fois entre tous
les acteurs de la chaîne et c'est déjà
ce qui est fait aujourd'hui mais qui a
évolué quand même on a vu on a vu
puisqu'on est un acteur ancien on l'a
dit et engagé sur les marchés
hospitaliers de ville depuis de
nombreuses années on a vu les
couvertures de stock évoluer et
notamment dans certains casses se
réduire donc je pense qu'elle doit
continuer à être partagé le plus
possible pour qu'il y ait au plus près
des patients et à chaque étape
suffisamment de stocks parce que ça
permet de répondre au mieux aux à-coups
et ensuite quand on se place dans un
objectif de de sécurisation puisque ça a
été évoqué
précédemment peut-être focaliser les
efforts sur des médicaments très
particuliers si là il doit y avoir des
mises en place de stock
s spécifiques individuel évidemment en
tout cas des industriels comme nous
aurons besoin du soutien de la force
publique pour constituer ces stocks
supplémentaires c'est certain
moi je voudrais rajouter quelque chose
si vous avez parlé aussi des matières
premières à des consommables et on n'a
pas répondu sur ce point aujourd'hui mon
télescope côté laboratoire c'est du
curatif et en médecine on nous apprend
qu'il faut faire du préventif c'est bien
de faire du préventif et si on si on
veut faire du préventif en fait il faut
adresser la chaîne en amont toute la
chaîne je vous donne un exemple
nous on utilise des filtres stérilisants
pour fabriquer nos médicaments
injectables on avait des délais
d'approvisionnement sur les filtres qui
étaient de quelques semaines à quelques
mois et puis du jour au lendemain s'est
passé à plus d'un an sur certains
filtres
et quand on a cette problématique là ça
peut bloquer complètement une chaîne de
de production sans possibilité de réagir
rapidement puisque c'est des références
qui peuvent être inscrites dans le
dossier d'AMM donc si vous voulez passer
sur un nouveau fournisseur de filtre il
faut tout requalifier ça prend des mois
ça coûte une fortune et donc la solution
c'est vraiment de renforcer toute la
chaîne aussi bien au niveau des
consommables des matières premières que
du laboratoire
oui c'est pour rebondir là dessus c'est
c'était d'ailleurs une proposition de
pôle format d'avoir une approche globale
c'est-à-dire pas uniquement les
fabricants mais les fabricants de
principes actifs les fabricants de
composants et c'est ce que nous on vit
en partie de par notre organisation le
fait d'avoir des partenaires locaux ou
continentaux bien identifiés en place
depuis de nombreuses années c'est une
c'est une ressource ça ne répond pas à
tout on évoquait les stocks nous on a
mis en place des doubles sourcings sur
certains nombre de composants critiques
notamment sur nos ampoules auprès de
grands fabricants européens
en début en début de cette année l'un
des deux fabricants nous a dit une des
quatre références que vous m'achetez je
l'arrête je l'arrête définitivement sans
délai de prévenance sans possibilité de
se retourner l'autre fournisseur qui est
pourtant une grande multinationale
nos a dit moi je ne pourrais pas couvrir
complètement ce que prenait l'autre
c'est une société qui implantée en
Allemagne parce que je ne peux pas
passer en trois équipes parce que je
n'arrive pas à recruter
c'est pas la France c'est l'Allemagne
mais on vit la même chose en France
aujourd'hui il y a aussi des questions
de ressources de ressources humaines
j'évoquais tout à l'heure l'aspect
pilotage on a vraiment besoin je pense
que collectivement on arrive à
repositionner notre industrie comme un
acteur de santé et un élément
de la chaîne un élément important de la
chaîne pour qu'il ait sa juste
reconnaissance que les jeunes
générations aient envie d'y travailler
et de rejoindre de rejoindre cette
carrière parce que même au-delà de
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'industrie
en France malheureusement c'est devenu
un secteur qui ne parle plus
à beaucoup de monde
alors que c'est un élément de richesse
et de souveraineté il y a quelques jours
a été voté un projet de loi important
sur
l'installation de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires
moi j'appelle de mes vœux peut-être une
démarche un petit peu similaire dans le
domaine de la santé pour moi ce sont des
sujets aussi stratégiques
juste de revenir sur un la question de
la transparence avec la NSM que vous
avez évoquée sur sur puisque vous
témoignez de ne pas savoir quelle est la
cause de la sur demande auprès de vous
et donc
[Musique]
que finalement regarder comme étant un
outil de diminution de la dépense
publique en matière de santé publique
puisque vous n'avez pas en contrepartie
la possibilité d'amener sur nos marchés
une innovation de rupture qui qui
vous permettrait de faire l'équilibre à
l'instar de ce que font d'autres
d'autres laboratoires on le sait
du coup votre statut et vos négociations
au sein du CEPS sont ne devrait vous ne
devriez pas avoir le même la même nature
de négociation avec le CEPS que d'autres
laboratoires qui proposent les deux
je
vous laisserai prendre à ça et puis
sinon on sait que un certain nombre de
donc vous il y a pas de brevet donc on a
bien compris il y a un certain nombre de
médicaments matures pour lesquels on
compte plus fabriquer puisque on nous a
témoigné aux Hospices civils de de Lyon
que sur un fameux curare il a fallu
retrouver la recette la monographie
comme comme disent les professionnels et
ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi de
transparence et est-ce que c'est ça fait
vraiment défaut est-ce que ça pourrait
traîner nécessaire pour ces produits
très banal d'usage très fréquents et non
moins très essentiel et qui pourront
pour lesquelles pour autant on a
complètement perdu le savoir-faire
alors dans le désordre effectivement et
d'ailleurs on a bien ressenti dans les
échanges avec le CEPS que c'était un
petit peu je sais pas comment dire un
vide un vide de fonctionnement pour eux
c'est comme on ne peut pas se
positionner dans cette situation
je vais employer un terme un peu
grossier de donnant-donnant ou
voilà on a effectivement plus grand
chose à donner on a déjà donné parfois
des remises ou de la clause de
sauvegarde donc ça reste compliqué et on
est effectivement un petit peu face à
une impasse qu'on décrivait tout à
l'heure sur ce que vous avez ok avec la
NSM
c'est vraiment pas une question de
transparence parce que je dirais de par
notre historique et
je dirais les échanges rapprochés qu'on
peut avoir avec la NSM à travers du Plan
Canicule chaque année je vais je vais
préciser mon propos en fait c'est comme
ce qu'on disait avec le CEBS la doctrine
c'est une question de fonctionnement
aujourd'hui je pense que la NSM n'a pas
la latitude de partager les données des
autres entreprises elle elle serait
volont à mon avis volontiers prête à le
faire pour faciliter les choses mais
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si ce sont
des questions réglementaires ou légales
qui n'en empêche mais elle ne peut pas
le faire pour prendre un exemple concret
on avait eu un échange en fin d'année
dernière avec elle
par rapport à la situation de nos
confrères la société Carline dans le
Nord qui était en difficulté et ça
commençait à impacter les fournitures
il a fallu plusieurs plusieurs jours
pour que la NSM trouve je dirais les
bons dispositifs pour être capable de
donner une visibilité des besoins qui
étaient couverts par cette entreprise
pour que les acteurs qui étaient autour
de la table évaluent ce qu'il pouvait ce
qu'il pouvait faire donc je pense
là-dessus je ne sais pas répondre si
c'est légal si c'est réglementaire mais
il y a aujourd'hui une limitation qui
évidemment freine les échanges freinent
la réactivité et qui fait aussi quelque
part supporter
l'entièreté de la charge du pilotage à
la NSM ce qui est peut-être aussi un
petit peu un petit peu déloyal parce que
c'était pas une accusation mais à force
d'avoir réparti les compétences sur tout
un tas de structures finalement chacun
se renvoie la balle et puis de temps en
temps il y en a un qui joue le rôle de
bouc émissaire aussi enfin c'est je
comprends bien je vous propose il
n'empêche que du coup il y a quand même
un problème d'anticipation ça c'est une
des failles du système parce que
des poches de de de
solutions
s'il y en a plus il y en a plus et donc
c'est sur le plan d'eau sanitaire c'est
un vrai danger pour la santé publique
vous l'avez dit ce sont des produits je
sais pas comment on peut dire
communique
qui peuvent paraître assez simple
néanmoins qui qui nécessite
un savoir-faire et des moyens des moyens
industriels et humains importants et
aujourd'hui comme ce sont devenus d'une
initialisation très courante et très
nombreuses ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir une capacité à fournir déployée
et développer et en fait un seul acteur
n'est pas capable à lui tout seul de
tout fournir quel qu'il soit en France
on a des acteurs nationaux des acteurs
internationaux aucun d'entre eux n'est
capable de couvrir tout donc
effectivement il faut sûrement peut-être
à l'aune de ce pilotage un peu plus
large donner aussi à la NSM des
capacités et des instructions pour
qu'elles puissent aller aller plus loin
mais c'est ça reste compliqué pour
prendre un exemple concret ça a été
beaucoup évoqué la triple la triple
épidémie de la fin d'année dernière et
notamment l'indisponibilité de
d'amoxicilline
dans un certain nombre de situations
cette situation s'est reportée sur des
traitements mécaniques je m'explique
nous on fournit du clan de sodium vous
l'avez dit et je pense que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent le clan de
sodium en dosette pour nettoyer les yeux
ou le nez dans certains cas et le nez
des enfants
ce report de la non-disponibilité de
l'amoxicilline à générer une
surconsommation des douzaines de Clarens
de sodium qui sont devenus aussi entre
guillemets pas suffisamment disponible
et par rebond sur les flacons de clan de
sodium injectable
puisque produit stérile
disponible en grande quantité on pouvait
prélever avec une seringue et nettoyer
assez facilement le nez des enfants à
notre niveau d'entreprise c'était
complètement imprévisible vous pouvez
pas imaginer que de report en report on
allait arriver sur sur ces présentations
et factuellement on s'est retrouvé au
mois de décembre avec une un doublement
quasiment de des demandes sur un certain
nombre de ces présentations donc c'est
vraiment un sujet très compliqué qui
nécessite je pense un engagement
collectif et coordonné
moi je voulais revenir un petit peu sur
la question du CEPS et des propositions
constructives
moi ma première proposition ça serait de
séparer le budget pour les innovations
et le budget pour les médicaments
matures aujourd'hui on a une enveloppe
globale où on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas
on peut essayer de tordre le problème
dans tous les sens tant qu'on restera
dans ce système là on aura des
commissions qui se tiendront année après
année où on reverra les mêmes problèmes
et on essaiera de faire des propositions
qui ne seront pas suivis des faits
il faut qu'on ait un budget pour les
médicaments matures et que le prix des
médicaments matures soit fixés au prix
de revient industriels plus une marche
qui sera décidée par la loi
aujourd'hui le CEPS n'a pas la capacité
technique de d'évaluer le prix revient
industriel d'un médicament
je crois que ça avait été expliqué
d'ailleurs par le président BOUYOU
lorsqu'il a été reçu par cette assemblée
je pense qu'il faut donner les moyens au
CPS d'évaluer le prix d'un médicament
qui
qu'il veut fixer c'est clairement pas
simple c'est pour ça que ça nécessite
une expertise je pense que la DGE a
sûrement une bonne partie de cette
expertise
et ça permettra aussi je pense
d'apporter un petit peu de transparence
dans les dans les discussions et de
sortir de ce mode de fonctionnement ou
quelque part il peut y avoir parfois un
peu de défiance
il y a quelques années aussi à la DGCCRF
avec conduit ce type de d'action de
d'évaluation comparative de prix de
revient donc je suis convaincu que dans
les différents services de l'État il y a
des il y a des compétences qui
pourraient être mobilisées
pour que ce soit pas trop externalisé
et
donc juste pour rebondir sur une
direction on va terminer là-dessus à moi
qui ai d'autres remarques que vous
souhaitez
nous transmettre maintenant
sur ce dont vous venez de témoigner
est-ce qu'il y a un retour d'expérience
cette histoire des flacons enfin la
chaîne en cascade ce qu'on appelle
l'arbre des causes
et donc normalement enfin c'est assez
classique de faire fonctionner les
choses de cette façon
et est-ce que est-ce que à tout le mois
la NSM quand même colis je ces arbres
des causes entre guillemets c'est c'est
et dans la perspective de de cette
proposition qui semble-t-il nous sera
faite peut-être allaité peut-être à la
rentrée en matière d'organisation et de
gestion de la situation sur les pénuries
de médicaments donc la fameuse mission
interministérielle est-ce que ces arbres
déco sont tous colligés pour pouvoir
être utiles à mettre en pratique on
pourra jamais tout envisager mais au
moins ce qu'on a déjà vécu peut-être
peut-on en tirer l'expérience
alors je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
points et je l'ai rappelé
dès 2003 la NSM et les industriels ont
travaillé ensemble justement sur ces
situations et les arbres des causes pour
mettre en place des dispositifs
spécifiques le plan canicule qui est en
neuf chaque année
aujourd'hui je peux pas m'exprimer vous
le comprendrez bien au nom de la NSM
mais je pense que comme chacun d'entre
nous la mobilisation sur les ressources
sur les ruptures ça mobilise énormément
de ressources et c'est vrai chez nous
mais je pense que c'est sûrement vrai
aussi du côté de la NSM
il y aura besoin de plus de ressources
mais est-ce que c'est pas finalement une
action
curative plutôt que préventive parce que
typiquement chez nous on mobilise à peu
près chaque semaine
20% des effectifs à différents moments
au travers de réunions sur ces sujets là
pour anticiper pour gérer les situations
parce que
des risques de tension on a envie tout
le temps en fait
un fournisseur qui devait nous livrer
un composant de moi avant une production
et qui nous annonce qu'il y a un retard
sans être en mesure de nous confirmer si
vraiment il pourra tenir un délai
réaliste par rapport à la production
envisagée donc on est déjà dans
l'urgence de chercher une solution
palliative qui n'est pas toujours
possible comme ça a été évoqué
prioriser aussi
les libérations de l'eau puisqu'on nous
en ce qui nous concerne on fabrique
chaque semaine trois lot de médicaments
différents chaque jour donc ça fait une
quinzaine de lots différents qui sortent
de nos chaînes de production tous ne
sont pas libérés en même temps on a vu
que les temps de cycles se rangent donc
on fait des priorités aussi en fonction
des situations des besoins et tout ça
c'est un pilotage extrêmement fin qui
mobilise des acteurs de la Supply des
acteurs de la Libération pharmaceutique
et je pense que c'est la même chose du
côté de la NSM on a régulièrement des
interlocuteurs qu'on commence maintenant
à connaître sur le sujet mais ils ont
comme nous des limites humaines donc
après avoir où est-ce que je dirais
notre pays souhaite fixer le curseur
mais évidemment si on souhaite aller
plus loin plus fort il y aura besoin de
moyens supplémentaires je pense que vous
les avez auditionnés je connais pas le
nombre de personnes qui travaillent à
l'unité rupture
mais je crois pas que ça soit ça soit
très important et sûrement aussi
s'appuyer sur d'autres d'autres entités
publiques on a évoqué tout à l'heure la
GEPS j'ai vu que vous aviez reçu santé
publique France anciennement et Prusse
qu'on connaissait bien aussi chacun peut
contribuer en fait il faut vraiment
créer une chaîne coordonnée
je suis désolé mais
on nous témoigne de disparité dans les
pénuries d'un territoire à l'autre voire
d'une pharmacie à l'autre c'est juste de
votre point de vue à vous alors vous
vous êtes plutôt hospitalier enfin il y
a quand même quelques vous faites les
deux et d'ailleurs je voulais des
oublier de vous demander mais la part
hôpital est
[Musique]
hors hôpital pour vous dans votre
activité et est-ce que vous constatez
aussi cette difficulté pour certains
territoires et le caractère extrêmement
changeant de la pénurie finalement
alors pour répondre sur les proportions
aujourd'hui il y a 45% de notre activité
qui est faite en ville donc médicament
remboursé 27% à l'hôpital
c'est très difficile de répondre à la
disparité puisque nous on ne livre pas
jusqu'au bout de chaîne en tout cas en
ville on passe par les grossistes très
partiteurs
néanmoins c'est un réseau avec lequel on
collabore depuis de nombreuses années
qu'on connaît bien et qui maille à notre
sens extrêmement bien le territoire
puisque même dans certains cas il
apporte des réponses quotidiennes aux
hôpitaux ça nous arrive d'avoir des
échanges avec certains hôpitaux qui ont
besoin en quelques heures et nous on ne
sait pas livré en quelques heures un
médicament en tout cas en moins de en
moins de 24 heures
qu'il passe directement par les
grossistes donc là dessus le maillage il
existe après c'est évidemment et je
pense que ça a été le cas pendant la
crise la crise covid de quelle manière
on a loue de les médicaments de manière
la plus fine et entre laboratoire et
grossiste on essaye notamment dans des
situations de pénurie de livrer au mieux
notamment sur la situation qui a été
évoquée tout à l'heure on a mis en place
avec la NSM des donc c'est à dire qu'on
livrait une proportion de ce qui était
demandé par chaque grossiste à l'aune de
ce qu'il avait consommé précédemment
donc si demander mille ce qui était 25%
de plus que d'habitude on lui livrait
80% des milles donc normalement tout le
monde gardait un peu près à peu près la
même proportion néanmoins il peut y
avoir des des disparités forcément dans
des situations épidémiques on voit bien
sur un territoire que tout le monde le
suit pas le subit pas de la même manière
après sur sur la partie hospitalière
c'est plus difficile de répondre puisque
là on ne couvre pas forcément tout le
territoire puisqu'il y a des marchés sur
lesquels on est engagé d'autres non
mais je
serai plus je dirais dubitatif sur le
sur le risque puisque là normalement je
dirais les les entreprises sont engagées
dans des marchés répondre à ces marchés
et si elles ne sont pas en capacité de
répondre ça a été aussi évoqué il y a
des mécanismes de
d'achat pour compte ou qui sont en place
et qui permettent de mobiliser d'autres
fournisseurs si nécessaire
bien je vous remercie beaucoup pour la
clarté de vos réponses
et des documents oui tout à fait tout à
fait merci beaucoup
merci à vous